[Music]
boy it's a crazy year in the NFL the
Jets just beat the bill Super Bowl
champion Rams are three and five and the
Packers have lost five in a row and
speaking of the Packers they claimed
Jonathan Abram off waivers today so it
didn't take long for the former Raider
first rounder to find a home he posted
on social media how it was an honor and
privilege to suit up for the silver and
black you know the Montreal wants a
Raider always a Raider he said it breaks
his heart to leave posting he never felt
he or if he felt he'd always be a Raider
forever well it's a reality-based
business and the reality is you need to
constantly prove yourself really you've
got to be an asset in the NFL perform
help the team win then you'll be
rewarded Raiders need some of those
assets to perform as Derek Carr says on
both sides of the ball
like this is a team game you know like
it's not just all on them if we turn the
ball over and give them the ball at
Midfield every time you know it's really
hard to play defense that way or if we
you know we don't get a first down when
we're backed up we're making a shorter
field like we're making it hard such a
team game that you know fantasy football
has turned it into well they didn't give
me my point so it must be that farther
it must be it says a football is a team
football game all right the cops